[Musique]
la fête d'Halloween fait son retour au
château de Dampierre pendant les
vacances de la toussin le domaine se
prête au jeu citrouille tourbillon de
crisantthème bougie un décor qui ne
laisse pas indifférent je me suis posé
la question c'est comment on peut avoir
autant de citrouille et c'est
remarquablement décoré et c'est bien
c'est c'est génial je trouve et j'ai
c'est une excellente idée ça va très
bien avec le verre avec la plousse qui
est magnifique non non c'est c'est très
beau c'est non non c'est bien faut
continuer également au programme de ces
vacances des ateliers et des animations
pour les petits et les grands on a pas
mal de personnes qui vont venir pour
voir les décorations qu'on a mis qui
vont venir aussi pour les enfants pour
leur permettre aussi tout simplement de
d'avoir cette lecture de compte on a
aussi des balades à poneis donc ça leur
permet de faire une sortie
tranquillement et pas très loin de Paris
pour les vacances le domain propose des
tarifs réduits à partir de 3,50 € la
date à ne pas manquer le samedi 28
octobre le domaine restera ouvert
jusqu'à 22h pour la nuit des châteaux